hey what's up guys my name is HNO and
welcome to episode 83 of game
programming so this is a bit of a
different episode as and then so we're
in our effects right now and I've never
ever done a tutorial in After Effects
before this isn't really gonna be a
tutorial though I'm not gonna teach you
guys how to use After Effects because
it's kind of irrelevant to game
programming which is of course the name
of this series because it's not
programming but you guys didn't want me
to show you how I made the sprites so
I'm gonna do that right now in front of
you guys basically so again I have no
idea how to do this because it's not
gonna be like a tutorial but if you got
I guess I'll just you know go ahead and
do stuff and Hum know right my way
through it so I've got a new project
here and it's called sprites
I just saved it in court and I called
sprites so I'm going to um I'm gonna
make a new composition now and I'm just
gonna call this probably gonna call
grass okay um in fact hang on first
thing I want to do is actually import a
file that I saved that is a screenshot
of um of what the game currently looks
like because I thought it'd be a good
idea to have something to reference by
so we've got this screenshot here I'm
just gonna drag that into the new
composition button here and I'll answer
one question in a minute as well because
um I know that's probably what's in your
mind so this is what the game looks like
right now so the question that most of
you are probably thinking is why on
earth are you using After Effects why
aren't using Photoshop or a similar
application but probably you're gonna be
like why are you using Photoshop the
reason is I I don't know how to use
Photoshop okay I do only basic stuff
though like I know how to use Photoshop
in terms of I don't know a crop an image
and you know maybe draw something on top
of it I don't know blend layers maybe
create some nice text with some some um
was it like blending options and some of
that really basic knowledge okay
whereas with After Effects I've been
using After Effects for the past seven
to eight years for its intended purpose
which is video effects basically video
editing and still that not really
editing but you know what I mean video
video composition so that's why basedgod
I have loads of experience in After
Effects I'll have a professional
experience in offer of exit
paid working some of that so that's why
After Effects is might go to fit pretty
much anything that um you know that
needs to happen in terms of um video
editing and and the other thing is it
has some really nice features as well so
over the past like a year or so I've
actually started using it a lot more for
um
first up for image applications anyway
let's get back into this sprite stuff so
this is what I again looks like right
now which is cool I think I actually
honestly have nothing against this grass
- I think it looks really well I just
like what it looks like walls not so
much floor no and player definitely not
okay so grass I think is okay we
probably won't change that the walls the
walls ain't changing let's start with
the walls so we've got kind of a brick
pattern going on here and I like that so
I'm probably keep that so let's let's go
to composition new composition if you
guys don't have After Effects by the way
probably download trial from adobe.com
or you could probably acquire you know
by other means but either way it's it's
about a thousand dollars you if you want
to purchase it so it's not it's not
super super expensive in fact probably a
bit less than thousand dollars but it's
definitely not shaped so I'm you know
you're cool so let's make a new
composition we'll make it 16 by 16
because that is the size of a sprite and
we're gonna call it wall okay so now
what we've got is a composition it's
like 11 seconds long I want to quickly
make it like in fact that probably
better I'm gonna quickly make it 1 frame
long ok did that again let's make it
like 10 frames long just in case I want
to animate something probably not though
okay so now that we've got this
composition here we need to basically
start by making a layer because we've
all that there's nothing here right now
so laying new texts not text why don't I
go to text layer new solid and we'll
make it maybe about the color that we
want our wall to be so that and
I'm gonna hit just hit okay okay so I'm
again with the text layer what is opera
okay so um let's uh let's okay well
since we want kind of a brick thing
let's hit up um let's hit up grid
because there's an effect called grid
that can actually pretty much provide us
with a grid which is going to look like
thingy so I'll probably make the border
about one let's say where's the size so
if I change the size so within high
sliders we can maybe make it one by one
pixel wide hang on and the border the
board is one as well so hang on is this
referring to the width of each it
wouldn't be with it that's the border
not okay so well adjust this to maybe
about two or so because one just makes
them on top of each other that's
probably a bit too much so um I don't
ever want to make it with a bit well
maybe like that it's kind of looking
okay um let's change the blending mode I
don't know well we've got this solid
behind it so something like screen I
don't like this crosses of light either
so maybe like stencil alpha that might
look nice
and let's offset it by the way this is
this is this is not gonna be like a
straightforward thing I've no I have not
made these price yet so I'm just making
I'm just doing as I go along so um you
know you're gonna have to forgive the
you know trial era stuff and seeing what
works what doesn't work but that's what
we got right now so we need to make it
kind of like a stony kind of texture
right so let's make an you solid I'll
call this one Saturn I'll start naming
my layers making the same causes metal
and I'm actually gonna go to effects
process I've been fractal and I get some
nice fractal noise in here so no I
wasn't great I actually probably just
hmm let's hide that for a minute
oh wait put it somewhere okay rattle
noise so we can't I want to create a um
I guess you kind of want to create a
make it um I don't know a lot about
confessors just playing around seeing
what works so um yeah this is what
making surprises like okay so let's zoom
out where is that that isn't transform
and scale okay so that's looking pretty
good the contrast probably bit too high
so you can see that if if I kind of hide
this we are getting a bit of a rocky
texture I may want to I'm not happy with
the fact that unfortunately our our
sprites are pretty low resolution which
is why this is a pixel by the way this
is what one pixel looks like I know
we're zoomed in like friggin 256 25000
percent but that is what one pixel looks
like so actual sizes like this so we are
dealing with very small sprites here
which is why it's incredibly limited
what we can do
so I'm actually considering changing the
actually hands a dream to change the
size of the sprites because um I just
realized this 16 by 16 is really nothing
but we'll see how it goes let's dim the
brightness down maybe about negative 20
or so and you can see what was trying to
kind of get a um I guess no uh rocky
kind of texture here play around with
this a bit I think I want to stick with
self linear evolution this will kind of
give you more Said's
all different sides I think zero is
actually pretty good I think I'm pretty
good here um hmm let's see okay this is
pretty much the same stuff so play
around with this so my Gibson I'm saying
I'm pretty happy with zero there um
honestly that looks pretty good to me um
for a stone thing so if we total this
one back on we can see that we're kind
of um that's fine actually
okay so we're kind of getting a grid
kind of look here and you can see how
that kind of looks um so what we can do
is go back to the screenshot real quick
and if we dry out these walls which are
tiny by the way
because we are all surrendering at a
four times resolution so 400% actually
it looks like it's not four hundred
percent let's dim it down a bit okay so
let's just match it roughly let's make
sure that we did set the stuff to not be
anti aliased there's a button here
called them I think if you set it to
draft mode rather than thingy mode and
it will look a lot nicer for pixel stuff
okay so it's looking pretty good I'm
gonna just resize it a bit and we're
gonna see what this looks like roughly
whoops just moving the anchor point who
be in the top right corner so that when
we scale it down it will scale from that
point pretty cool stuff got a bunch of
times move it down okay so now we're
starting to see what this looks like if
we watch you use this spot and the best
thing is oops the best thing the coolest
thing about this is that if I change
anything to do with the wall it will
update automatically here so that's what
we look like right now yeah that's not
bad but I do really like this color it's
kind of like a bluish color so if I go
back to a wall here and let's well we
could do a bunch of things we could
actually just make a new adjustment
layer right now and maybe up the blue
stuff so if I go to curves and we drag
out some curves and maybe I just up the
blue basically we can get some nice blue
I'm just gonna probably get rid of some
of the right here and Garrett is on the
green as well well why don't I add some
green maybe we can make a nice curve
here to get rid of there I guess is
giving us a purple
okay that's obviously very um for what
we can kind of change the opacity to
blend that a bit more I can kind of give
us a matching color here there's quite a
bit of green in this as well so in fact
if you just hover your mouse over that
I'll tell you exactly how much I saw
each so it's 51 red 62 green and 65 blue
so there's still quite a bit of green in
there so if we go back to wall here we
can go back to the green channel here
and probably spike it up a bit and you
can see they were kind of getting um got
way too much boyar this was looking like
now that's pretty good
that's a pretty close color as you can
say um so yeah what does that look like
um
brookies they're they're not really look
like bricks are they so let's go back to
wool and let's play around with this
grid thing what we could do is offset
parts of it that's probably a good idea
let's do something it's a bit advanced
but let's do something like that so I'm
just gonna solve those two layers what
we could do is I grab a mask here
probably a bad way of doing it but
anyway if I grab the mask here um I'm
just gonna select like an area here in
fact we should probably make this
correct so I might select exactly that
much yeah exactly that much okay and
then I can basically just move that
around so I can shift it like this so we
can get sort of a brick look that's not
really working is it nope okay let's
make sure that we um actually copy the
mouse very here and oops subtract it
I get that's not exactly what I had in
mind let's grab that one more time I
just want to get rid of those stripe
excells so this is fun isn't it office
tutorials
okay masks okay so that's not really
working is in hmm what we could do okay
you know what let's um get rid of this
grid thing for a minute yeah I think
what we could do instead is just grab a
black solid or maybe even pretty dark
right here
and what we could do is essentially is
probably just shouldn't have done that
it's just um hide bits of it if I change
this smart to that as well it'll look a
lot better
probably or in fact okay I don't know if
I like the UH you have the feathering is
kind of nice isn't it
okay now we're gonna have to do a look
at this a bunch of times how big should
these bricks be that's pretty good okay
okay yeah these videos gonna be long by
the way because obviously they're not
gonna accomplish too much because arts
arty videos
cool and then I guess we yeah that's
gonna look bad that I can them up with
that one there okay um
damn why does that no I can't I guess
that's fine
what I want what I might do though is
move them all down like one pixel there
we go I think that'll look a lot better
I guess now we got these guys I'm
actually just gonna a Joseph see them to
break and post them I'll call them two
bricks
I don't know and what I'm gonna do is
actually looking pretty prism just now
because I want I want I want to add on
the vertical bricks first so yeah by the
way I'm that I want to do that just to
look at that probably get rid of the
mask and move it up so I think the
position what if he's 0 0 yeah
that's half of that hey hey hey it's not
for that all there really are 45% thank
you so um since the anchor point is in
the middle makes sense I'm probably just
gonna grab a rectangle again and just no
not on this shape I never use shape
layers by the way if there are any
people in the comments who Pro After
Effects is ultra phases so what let me
know if you guys use shape layers
because I've never I never use them I
never found any for them they become a
useless in my opinion
I always just master stuff out like I'm
doing right now it does give you the
same effect so why don't so I'm thinking
that's pretty good for bricks so we'll
leave a gap of three in between
and one more I guess that's one light
whoops get rid of this so that's one
layer of bricks I guess so let's do it
look at that control date and I'll
probably bring this light down to here I
think we'll need one more there that's
all right
it's looking pretty good pretty good
okay cool so I'll keep doing that
control day
all right it's also like God
which one's the UM okay let's just keep
duplicating them I don't want to UM I
don't want to select the ones on top
that'll take too long
okay I'll do it look at one small so
that we can put these bad boys hmm all
the way up here where they belong
okay whoops okay awesome bricks so now
that we've got like what is this like 29
layers of bricks let's go lay a
pre-compose same thing as close as
pressing control shift say and I'll
colder mom holding bricks cuz that's
what they are so we essentially just put
Brooks into its own composition as you
can see mmm so now we want to play
around with the transfer modes to maybe
um but but in something like screen I
think we look pretty nice color classic
color burn and probably air burn the
colors call it dodge isn't gonna work
dissolve no does look cool but just not
for this purpose color lighten and I
don't think something like add might
look cool especially if we just make
sure that we oh yeah hmm Oh what we
could do actually this might be cooler
maybe yeah if we um let's just leave
that on normal if we grab a stone and
change its track not to be alpha
inverted or luma inverted that do
anything anything but um it did really
subtly that's way too subtle let's
change the color of this there to be
something online
laya oh right damn it
what changed for all days that's
annoying isn't it okay um this is a sit
through yes okay so let's do it for um
one of the verticals there we go so
layout solid settings if I make this
brighter um that's how I change my thing
okay cool mmm
welcome to a series where the channel
learns how to use After Effects okay
okay don't worry about chart mats um
just let's play around with V stuff yeah
okay so we could always turn down the
opacity if we wanted to make it yeah
that's something pretty good we honestly
I think the bricks might be too small
there that's why I'm sure also I'm not
happy with this repeating pattern here
so like you can see that there's a bit
of a burn here I might just go back to
the stern and probably select different
seed or I could increase the brightness
slightly oops negative 20 who I was I
meant and maybe decrease the contrast
40-ish give it more sanitized here mmm
it's not bad that's maybe play around
with the size of the bricks yeah what's
this then okay let me just sell it that
out quick and okay
man the scaling is just not good is it
absolutely not good um okay back to one
on here we go
mm-hmm now 100 even looks bad
what did we do there we go
okay it doesn't matter okay so now what
I want to do is basically add a light
here I want to add a point light
probably make it around pretty like
light blue will make it kyles shadows
none that will make a difference here oh
so the thing is we could do some really
cool stuff with this but the thing is
our sprites are 16 by 16 so if you guys
want to see um you guys want to see
sprites that are that are like maybe 128
128 like that or 64 by 64 let me know
I'll I'll up the resolution of our game
because um now that we're getting into
this stuff at some kind of yeah so this
is just our light right here okay cool I
know about that okay so let's um make
these layers 3d oops okay so at this
point I might actually just go to the
adjustment layer here and just sausage
disappear does adjustment layers not
we're okay here it is disappeared for a
minute what some kind of get that to
match so the idea with the light is that
it can make it look really cool but the
problem with a light is that it tends to
make it look you know like it's in one
place which is bad because we're kind of
tiling these tiles so you can see that
that probably looks okay grass and stuff
does not match at all in fact I'm gonna
quickly make another grasp right okay so
lay a new sari new composition close one
grass I'm probably just gonna take the
grass I've already have unfortunately
it's not all actually hang on a minute
I um have these sprites don't send
resources textures appreciate there it
is bring that out let's find our grasp
right and let's just go play set this to
be like that this is the old this is the
old stuff this man
yes yes scared of that Osbourne level I
believe then don't be right there'll be
it all right there it is okay so there's
our original grass okay I'm going to
also crop this cool by masking it out
okay so we've got we got our original
grasp right here what I could do
potentially is actually at a new light
let's make the layer 3d layer new light
oops we could make it kind of blue as
well so we're kind of making like a
thunder knee kind of feel I'm not sure
if this is the aesthetic we're going for
right now but we could certainly play
around that and you can see that if we
do somewhat something like this it might
look really cool for our grass so if we
bring our grass over here and scale it
up however many times it wants to be
scaled
let's see what we could do here is I'm
really up the quality of our sprites
okay cool sorry about that here and
duplicate it a bunch of times just so we
can see what it looks like when we tile
them okay yeah so you can see kind of
the problem that happens when you tile
sprites that have lighting applied to
them the way that I have done it
you get that little like vignette kind
of thing which of course we could fix
and stuff it you know so that's what
grass car looks like now let's maybe
complete this and we must not have done
this correctly right yeah I was just hot
to tell with all the grass went where it
ended and where it began so let's
probably move that up okay there we go
so I'll grab one more yeah another row
whoops okay so that's kind of a grass
looking like that's kind of a walls are
looking like it's kind of what our games
looking like let's go back to grass real
quick and adjust this light here make it
a bit less pronounced you can still see
the edges there you know I mean that's
the only issue the other obvious thing
is not using these as tiles and actually
doing it differently and that is of
course why just using textures actual
textures that texture the entire area
that could be really cool to explore
actually because we've never cut weave
we haven't covered anything like that
for this series so that would be um
they'll be a cool video I think but
that's kind of what we're looking like
right now
let's just keep duplicating that I guess
alright yeah one more time okay so
that's kind of what the games looking
like now which is pretty good
okay I feel like um I feel like this is
possibly a bad idea and the reason I
feel like it's a bad idea is because I'm
about to start one up wanting to make
this game like graphically look amazing
but the problem is it might not really
work this is actually not bad though
wait do that light a bit maybe if we
shift it was like one direction
definitely not because they were what I
would have done like what I could have
done brother is if I grab his grass I'll
just quickly break him throws this got
this wall quick quickly freaking chose
that as um call it wall comp
otherwise I'm getting to grass things
bad idea what I would have done is
probably grab this light pop it here and
then add it globally so like um like
this right like that if I just make this
3d like that and of course that looks
awesome and similar obviously a similar
thing with that stuff as well but the
problem is with that is that I have to
rewrite the entire game engine to
probably support lighting like this so
that's the only issue yeah but of course
it would look better anyway guys I think
that's what we're gonna wrap up this
episode again programming this is more
much more of a um art kind of
perspective if you guys want to skip
these skip these episodes that's fine be
my guest but um the way that I'm gonna
release these is um I think if we hit
200 likes I'm gonna really an episode of
gaming every day so that's gonna be
quite a challenge alone but if we hit
300 likes per video then I'm going to
release two episodes of gamma gramming
every day
right I said it okay so hit the like
button if you guys want to see more
episodes but other than that let me know
what you think about textures okay if I
should make them higher resolution
because I think um I think it would look
really cool if we do that but anyway um
yeah
Cherno out
you